things have suddenly taken a very ugly
turn for donald trump's i guess
former i do we know former lawyer rudy
giuliani
a rudy giuliani's apartment and office
have been raided by federal
investigators as part of an
investigation
into possible crimes committed by rudy
giuliani this is an absolute blockbuster
situation
for a number of reasons but understand
that rudy is being investigated for
possible crimes committed
while working as the personal lawyer for
a sitting president of the united states
there is a ton we don't yet know about
what's going on but we are slowly
learning it
the new york times has a very good
report what we know is that search
warrants were executed
at both rudy's home in office
investigators seized what are being
reported as multiple laptops and mobile
phones
this took place yesterday morning at 6
am
that's relevant if you come in at 6 a.m
at both the home and office
simultaneously
i asked on twitter actually is the
execution
of the rudy search warrant at 6am
relevant if you do it that way
is it a sign you're worried he'll try to
destroy evidence
if you come in calmly or schedule it and
indeed former fbi agent asha rangapa
responded to me that quote
most searches happen early in the
morning primarily there is simply a
greater likelihood that the subject will
be home
as you note it will also be less likely
to be observed with time to destroy
evidence etc
and in the case of dangerous individuals
it's safer for
agents now of course rudy's lawyer and
rudy himself are saying this is
outrageous
this is not necessary certainly not at
6am he's being treated like a criminal
this is a 76 year old man
rudy giuliani's lawyer robert costello
remember
magga means making attorneys get
attorneys
trump's lawyer's lawyer robert costello
put out a statement saying quote
what they did today was legal thuggery
why would anyone do this to anyone
why would you do this to anyone let
alone someone who was the associate
attorney general
united states attorney the mayor of new
york city and the personal
lawyer to the 45th president of the
united states
that'll be evaluated if feds acted
inappropriately with the raid
or doing it at 6am or whatever it'll be
determined but in the meantime
a real practical question is do we
really think evidence is still around
and what i mean is these guys have had
more than a year to destroy it all
haven't they almost certainly done it or
at least tried it is true that the fbi
has a way
of recovering things you think you've
deleted but the point is rudy knows he's
been at least a possible target for a
while
one other takeaway they are starting to
claim on the right
that this is a biden directed political
hit job
we uh have no reason to believe that
that's the case but we actually have
reason to believe it's not and the new
york times reported
that investigators were looking for a
search warrant to do this
and get rudy's mobile devices and such
while trump was still president
but political appointees of donald trump
to the justice department blocked it
so this actually predates joe biden they
were
investigating this during trump and they
weren't able to do the
search warrant because trump appointees
blocked it
so it is that obstruction not joe biden
which has led to this taking place
in april rather than when donald trump
was still president of the united states
truly stunning stuff how far will this
go as a problem for rudy we don't know
but it's not looking very good
later on in the show we'll hear from
rudy's son and his reaction to this
and we'll have continued coverage of
this on the david pakman show
instagram page make sure you are
following us there
at david pakman show follow me on
instagram david.pacman
one of our sponsors today is sheath
underwear
the weather is warming up and as many of
us know
that can be associated with sticking
rubbing
chafing with traditional underwear
sheath underwear
creates boxer briefs that solve it all
sheath underwear was developed by a u.s
soldier who spent time deployed in the
desert
he was looking for a way to be more
comfortable
and he designed something that's great
even just for everyday use
sheath boxer briefs have multiple
ergonomic
compartments in front to prevent
skin on skin contact keeping everything
separate cool dry and comfortable so
sheath underwear
will prevent the sweatiness and the
chafing and the readjusting
and sheath underwear is giving the david
pakman show audience 20
off when you go to sheath
slash pacman and use the promo code
pacman
my experience with sheath underwear has
been great
yours will be as well if you give it a
try the link is right underneath this
video don't forget to use that promo
code
pacman for twenty percent off